I'm a huge fan of Beyonce Beyonce is a
huge fan of the real Tamera Mowry
Housley reacts to the Beehive drama
there was a Beyonce jay-z gate with you
what is the reaction to everybody in the
Beehive freaking out Samara you didn't
freak out at all I really didn't I was
really confused cuz I just asked for
some gum and I'm a huge fan of Beyonce
Beyonce is a huge fan of the real and
yeah to get the President's Award if I
see him on a red card I'm asking for
some gum and you guys are always so real
on the real unless a lot of people right
now we're talking about Jesse's smallest
case can we get your reaction so the
outcome and the future of everything
going on with that yeah and that's what
I think I have learned by doing this
show just make sure if you're gonna give
an opinion especially when it's talking
about something like this make sure you
have all the facts so I'm just following
everything right now we're gonna give
more thoughts on that because I think
there's a lot of lessons learned in that
situation and it's something that we
have to keep talking about I have to
keep realizing about the story just
continues to unfold so it's hard to give
your opinion on something that you don't
have all the facts to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]